メンバーシップの新着記事が届きました
noteで読む
イーロン・マスクが静かに進出した重要な新事業とは
サイバーキャブがSNSでバズる裏で進む重要製品の開発
日本のSNSでは、アメリカで発表されたTESLAのサイバーキャブという自動運転タクシーが大変話題である。
ハンドルもブレーキもアクセルも存在せず、本当に完全に自動運転タクシーとして開発された車体で、自動で車が迎えにきて、目的地まで送ってくれる様子がSNSに大量に投稿されている。
2026年夏にはSpaceXがxAIを吸収して一気に上場をし、人工衛星ネットワークビジネス、宇宙ロケットビジネス、SNSビジネス、そして同じイーロン・マスクが運営するテスラの電気自動車・自動運転車ビジネスが注目されており、名実ともに世界有数のイノベーション企業となった。
エーアイ領域においても、トップを走るアンソロピック、続くオープンエーアイ、そしてグーグルら3社が西側諸国を寡占するなかで、Grokを引っ提げて参入してしばらくが経過した。
ビジネス向けにはアンソロピックのClaude Codeが躍進し、個人向けに強かったオープンエーアイはCodexでビジネス向けを取りに行き、グーグルはライトなモデルで軽快に動かし自社アプリとの連携性を高めている。
イーロン・マスクの参入は遅く、Grokは当初は話題をさらったが、個人、法人ともにユーザー数は3社ほど伸びていない。
Grokが伸びていなくて余っていたのか、SpaceX(xAI)は2026年、急進しすぎてジーピーユーが足りなくなったアンソロピックに、xAIのCorossusデータセンターを丸ごと月2000億円で貸し出すという超大型系契約を取りまとめた。
1人の経営者があまりにも多数の最先端事業をやっているので、どうしても目立つサイバーキャブやスターリンクなどに注目が集まりがちであるが、このようなニュースが流れていた時期に、イーロン・マスクが静かに進出した新事業分野がある。
のちにそれは記者やアナリストらにもリークされ、イーロン・マスクも参入について発表した。
日本ではあまり話題にはなっていない。
それはどんな事業なのだろう。
エーアイにおけるイーロン・マスクの進出した重要な領域とは、
ガスタービンブレードである。
イーロン・マスクが8月29日にXに投げた一本の投稿が、週明けの月曜日、ニューヨークしじょうで航空宇宙部品大手ハウメット・エアロスペースの株価を7パーセント以上押し下げ、1週間でハウメットは10パーセント以上も株価が低下した。
のちに、三菱重工業も1週間で5パーセント株価が低下した。
投稿の中身は、ロケットでも自動運転でもなく、
ガスタービンの「ブレードとベーン」を自社で鋳造する、
という話だった。
マスクは、SpaceXとTeslaがそれぞれ年間100ギガワット分の太陽光生産能力を急ピッチで整えているとしたうえで、それでも天然ガスは数年間、太陽光を補い、立ち上げるために必要だと書いた。
そして、天然ガスタービン発電の生産拡大を制約しているのはブレードとベーンの鋳造工程であり、SpaceXがこれを内製すればタービンの稼働開始を最大18カ月早められる、と続けた。
唐突に見えるが、この投稿は自発的な発表ではないし、ガスタービンはエーアイ領域において極めて重要な設備である。
同じ日の数時間前、米テック専門メディアのThe Informationが、SpaceXの求人票に「Blades and Vanes Foundry」という文言がはっきり書かれていることを発表していて、投資銀行やアナリストたちが、SpaceXの求人票から推定した場所と事業を手がかりに、SpaceXは3月から6月にかけてテキサス州バストロップにあるStarlink工場の隣接地を約830エーカー、東京ドームに換算して70個分ほど買い集めていたと突き止めたことを報じていた。
SpaecXのガスタービンブレードのオペレーション技術者募集ページ
求人票そのものも興味深い。
[EN]「Sr. Operations Engineer, Blades and Vanes Foundry」というポジションの説明文には、[/EN]
高頻度かつ大量のStarship飛行の未来において発電が極めて重要だ
、という趣旨の一文がある。
ロケット会社が発電の話をしている。
データセンターを動かす電気が足りない。
電気を作るタービンが手に入らない。
タービンが作れないのは、部品の鋳造が追いつかないからだ。
だったら鋳造から自分でやる。
マスクの思考はそういう順番で下りてきたのだろう。
ちょうど1年前の2025年8月にゆな先生が書いた記事で、
エーアイが利用されると三菱重工が儲かる理由、
というのがある。
このときにゆな先生はすでにガスタービンの重要性を詳細を解説していたのだが、ガスタービンの重要性はますます増加している。
エーアイデータセンターというのは24時間365日、フルパワーで電力を使う。
夜も他の国から海底ケーブルを通して来るユーザーしょりをするし、高額なジーピーユーをフル稼働させて金を稼がせたいので、24時間動かし続ける。
ソーラー発電のような昼間しかエネルギーを作れない電源は使い物にならず、24時間安定的に稼働する電源が必要となる。
凄まじい数でデータセンターが増えていけば、当然ながら電気は足りなくなる。
24時間安定的に稼働というと、圧倒的に原子力発電が重要なのだが、残念ながら原発を作るには日本でも数十年、海外でも10年以上の年月がかかる。
よって、この急激にじゅようが増えるフェーズでは原子力発電は有力ではない。
火力発電所を建設するのも良いが、CO2排出の問題などもあり、石炭や原油の発電所を大量に作るわけにもいかない。
そこで、1−2年ですぐに建設できるガスタービン発電は、これから約10年くらいは少なくとも凄まじい需要となることが明らかである。
ガスタービン発電装置は、3社、GE、シーメンス、三菱重工が寡占シェアを持っていて、後は小さな会社がいくつかあるレベルであって、急な投資拡大も見込めず、生産拡大が需要に全く追いついていない。
ここで冷静になっておきたいのは、
SpaceXが認めたのはあくまで鋳造部品への進出
であって、タービン一式を作るとは一言も言っていないことだ。
ガスタービンという製品の中で、最もきょうきゅうが細く、最も技術的に難しく、最も少数の企業に握られている部分にだけ、ピンポイントで手を突っ込もうとしている。
だからこそしじょうは、GE Vernovaでもシーメンス・エナジーでもなく、鋳造を生業とする
ハウメット(HMW)
の株を真っ先に売った。
翌火曜日には一部戻したものの、マスクの一言で時価総額が数十億ドル単位で動いた事実は変わらない。
本稿では、この一手を「マスクがまた派手なことを言った」で済ませず、なぜ鋳造なのか、なぜ今なのか、そして個人投資家としてどういう影響があるかを考えていきたい。
圧倒的にエーアイ用の電気が足りない
まず前提を揃えておきたい。
今のSpaceXは、もうロケットと衛星だけの会社ではない。
2026年2月にxAIを飲み込み、6月12日にナスダックにじょうじょうした。
ティッカーはSPCX。
初日の終値で時価総額はおよそ2兆ドル、史上最大のアイピーオーだった。
そして上場後初めての決算説明会で、イーロン・マスクは
2027年末までに、地上に少なくとも10ギガワットのデータセンターを作る
、と発言した。
日本の個人投資家にも縁のない話ではない。
SpaceXは公募株の3割を個人向けに回し、日本でもみずほ証券をアジアの販売幹事証券会社に指定して、有価証券届出書を出して販売した。
みずほと楽天証券は提携しているので、楽天でアイピーオーに応募していた人の多くが買えた。
ゆな先生は普段SBIを使っているので記念に買おうと思ったが当たらなかった。
この記事を読んでいる人の中にも、SPCXを何株か持っている人がいるかもしれない。
10ギガワットという数字がどれくらいかというと、大型の原子力発電所がだいたい1基で1ギガワットだから、原発10基分の電気を食う施設を1年ちょっとで建てる
と言っている。
日本全体の夏のピークじゅようが150ギガワット台だから、その15分の1をひとつの会社のデータセンター用で1年で建設してしまう計算になる。
我が国の発電施設は1年や10年で作られたものではなく、何十年もかけて150ギガワットに達してきたのだから、とんでもない話である。
チップの方は目処がついている。
エヌビディアと10ギガワット分の独占供給契約を結んだと報じられていて、モルガン・スタンレーも「チップ側はほぼ解決済み」とアナリスト記事で書いている。
問題は電気だ。
各社のアナリスト記事を読む限り、アナリストたちは2027年末時点の予測で5ギガワットのデータセンターしか作れないと見ている。
半分だ。
理由はシンプルで、電気がいつ手に入るか分からないからである。
xAIの歩み
xAIがどうやってここまで来たかを少し振り返る。
2024年、xAIはテネシー州メンフィスにColossusと名付けた巨大なデータセンターを、着工から122日という異常な速さで立ち上げた。
ゆな先生の近くでマンション建設が進んでいるが、1年以上経過したがまだ全然完成する気配はない。
122日で遥かに大きな巨大データセンターを作るのである。
このデータセンターをいま、アンソロピックに月2000億円で貸している。
速さの秘密のひとつが、電力会社の送電網が整うのを待たずに、敷地に移動式のガスタービンを並べて自前で発電してしまったこと
にある。
このやり方はその後も続いていて、ミシシッピ州サウスヘイブンの発電設備は2026年2月に27基のタービンで約495メガワットだったものが、7月には69基、1.7ギガワットにまで膨らんでいる。
5月に公開された上場関連の書類を読むと、SpaceXがここ数カ月で
xAIのデータセンター用のガスタービンに28億ドル以上を投じた
ことも分かった。
日本円で4000億円超を、タービンだけに使った。
それでも足りない。
ここが今回の話の核心の話である。
大型のガスタービンを作れる会社は、世界に実質3社
しかない。
GE Vernova、シーメンス・エナジー、三菱重工
少し小さくなればイタリアの
アンサルド
、新顔として韓国の
斗山エナビリティ
そしてこの3社の工場は今、エーアイブームで注文が殺到して完全に詰まっている。
GE Vernovaは6月末までの四半期だけで15ギガワット分を受注したいっぽう、出荷できたのは6ギガワット。
納期は3年以上で、
受注残は2030年まで埋まっている
とされる。
今日注文を入れても、モノが届くのは2029年か2030年
それでは2027年末の10ギガワットには間に合わない。
その間にエーアイビジネスは勝敗がついている。
ちなみに、電力会社の送電網につないでもらうのはもっと遅い。
アメリカでも日本でも、送電網への接続申請がなんねんも順番待ちになっていて、大型変圧器や開閉装置も2年先まで売り切れだと言われる。
だからエーアイ企業はこぞって、
送電網に頼らず敷地内で自前で発電するオフグリッド
の方向に流れた。
そこで頼るのがガスタービンで、その結果タービンがさらに足りなくなる。
じゅようがじゅようを呼ぶ循環となっている。
ゆな先生の予測通りであった。
だからイーロンマスクは、正規ルートの外側で手当たり次第に電気を集めてきた。
2026年7月、
投資会社フォートレスが移動式タービンの会社APR EnergyをxAIに売却していた
ことが分かった。
APR Energyの保有タービンは1月時点で約1ギガワット。
原発1つ分である。
移動式ガスタービンは臨時ですぐに設置できるが大きな電気出力を持つ。
東日本大震災で東京電力管内が電力不足に陥った時、タイ政府が持っていた移動式ガスタービンを日本に貸してくれた。
日本人の多くは忘れているかもしれないが、ゆな先生はよく覚えている。
そういうものがあるんだなという程度であったが、そういう細々としたニュースが後で投資家として効いてくる。
もうひとつ、フォートレス系から分かれた
FTAI Aviation
という会社がある。
もともと旅客機のジェットエンジンを整備する会社で、航空機エンジンを発電用に転用したタービンを扱っている。
FTAIは7月に、中国の合弁相手を通じて14億6500万ドルのタービン売却契約を「世界有数のクラウド事業者」と結んだと発表したが、SpaceXなのではないかと言われている
こうした継ぎ接ぎの電力を全部足し合わせて、2027年末までに3〜4ギガワット程度をやっと確保出来るだろうというのが、投資アナリストたちの予測であった。
3〜4ギガワットと10ギガワットでは、圧倒的に差があり、イーロン・マスクの目標には届かない。
これがガスタービンブレードの鋳造工場を建てる理由と言っていい。
お金の話をすると、
エーアイデータセンター1ギガワットあたりの売上機会(サーバー提供のクラウド・エーアイ提供会社として)は年間およそ500億ドルくらい
と言われている。
この数字を鵜呑みにする必要はないが、桁感だけ掴んでおけばいい。
1ギガワット分のデータセンターが18カ月遅れるということは、単純計算で750億ドルの売上機会が後ろにずれる
ということになる。
それだけの金額が動くなら、鋳造工場を1つ建てる投資など誤差の範囲になる。
マスクがインタビューで「profound game-changer(非常に大きなゲームチェンジャー)」と言っていたが、言ったのは、技術的な意味ではなく、たぶんこの計算のことだとゆな先生は理解している。
では、なぜタービンの生産は詰まっているのか。
工場が足りないのか、人が足りないのか。
実は、詰まっているのはタービン全体ではなく、その中のごく小さな部品である。
なぜブレード(動翼)とベーン(静翼)が問題なのか
イーロン・マスクが参入するのはガスタービンのBlade and Vaneと書いていて、Bladeは動翼、Vaneは静翼と日本語で表記される。
ガスタービンの中身を、ものすごくざっくり説明する。
ガスタービンの断面図(byゆな先生)
この図だと、左側①から空気を吸い込んで圧縮し、③で燃料を混ぜて燃やし、その燃焼ガスを後ろの④タービンに吹き付けて回す。
回った力で発電機を回す。
原理は飛行機のジェットエンジンと同じで、実際、大型のガスタービンはジェットエンジンの技術を陸に降ろしたものである。
問題は、燃焼ガスを吹き付けられる④のタービンの部分にある。
ここに並んでいる羽根がブレード(動翼)で、その手前でガスの流れを整える固定翼がベーン(静翼)。
ブレードとベーンは何重にも重なっていることもあるからこの図だとわかりにくいが、こういうやつである。
左がブレード(回転する)、右がベーン(動かず整流する)
燃焼室を出た直後のガスは、機種にもよるが摂氏1650度から2000度近い。
いっぽうで、
ブレードの材料であるニッケル基超合金の融点は、それより450度くらい低い
つまりこの部品は、自分が溶ける温度よりはるかに高温のガスの中で、毎分数千回転で回りながら、何万時間も形を保っていなければいけない。
放って置くと当然溶ける。
どうやって耐えているかというと、内側から冷やしている。
ブレードは中が空洞で、迷路のような細い通路が張り巡らされていて、圧縮機から抜いてきた比較的冷たい空気をそこに流す。
この写真でもわかるように、ブレードとベーンにはさらに表面には無数の小さな穴が開いていて、そこから空気を吹き出して羽根の表面に薄い空気の膜を作る。
その上にセラミックの断熱コーティングを吹き付ける。
トースターの中に氷を置いて、氷の中に冷えた空気を通しながら溶けないようにする、という感じの芸当である。
一見アホそうに見える行為だが、これで溶けない。
これを考えつく人間は凄いものである。
で、これをどう作るか。
ロストワックスという技術で作る。
精密鋳造の一種だ。
まずロウでブレードの原型を作る。
中にはセラミックの中子を仕込んでおく。
これが後で空洞の通路になる。
蝋型の周りにセラミックのスラリー(ドロドロ)を何層も塗り重ねて殻を作り、蝋を溶かして抜く。
空になった殻を真空炉に入れて、溶かした超合金を流し込む。
ここまでは、難しいとはいえ他の精密鋳造と似ている。
参考：ロストワックス法の製造工程
本当に難しいのは、そこから金属を固める工程である。
普通に冷やすと、金属は小さな結晶の粒がたくさん集まった状態で固まる。
粒と粒の境目が高温で弱くなり、そこから少しずつ伸びて壊れる。
金属は熱で伸縮するのだ。
真夏に線路が歪むニュースを見たことがある人もいると思う。
ちなみにゆな先生のふるさとに大昔にあった電車は廃線でなくなったので線路が歪むこともない。
だから最高級のブレードは、部品ひとつがまるごと一個の結晶になるように固める。
細かく理解はしなくてよいが、単結晶鋳造と呼ばれる技術で、殻の底に螺旋状の結晶選別部を設けておいて、複数の結晶の芽のうち一つだけを上に通し、その一個を羽根の先端まで成長させる。
炉から殻を引き抜く速度は1時間に数ミリ。
30センチのブレードなら、引き抜くだけで何時間もかかる。
速度がずれれば結晶の向きが狂い、その部品は廃棄になる。
型に入れて抜くというのはイメージだとすぽーんと抜ける感じがするが、そういうわけにはいかないのだ。
固まったらセラミックの中子を薬品で溶かし出し、コーティングを施し、レーザーや放電加工で冷却穴を何百と開ける。
歩留まりは、この業界の人が公の場では言いたがらないので詳細はゆな先生も知らない。
こんな工程を工業きぼで回せる鋳造会社は、世界に4社しかないとされる。
バークシャー・ハサウェイ傘下の
プレシジョン・キャストパーツ(非上場)
ハウメット・エアロスペース(上場)
、非公開の
コンソリデーテッド・プレシジョン・プロダクツ
(非上場)、そしてイギリスの
ドンキャスターズ
この4社で、高級な単結晶と一方向凝固のブレードしじょうの7〜8割を握っている。
日本勢だとIHIも頑張っているが、シェアはまだ小さい。
特に単結晶については、PCCとハウメットの2社でおよそ8割と言われる。
バフェットが2016年に約370億ドルでPCCを買ったのは、要するにこの部品を買ったようなものである。
しかも、この4社の炉を奪い合っているのは発電用だけではない。
同じ単結晶ブレードは旅客機のジェットエンジンにも使われていて、こちらは今、ボーイングとエアバスの増産に加えて、飛んでいるエンジンの交換部品じゅようで過去最高の景気にある。
航空とエーアイ、二つの波が同じ4社の同じ製造ラインに同時に押し寄せている。
なぜ新規参入がないのだろうか。
真空炉もセラミックも、金を出せば買える。
買えないのは、何十年分の製造データ
である。
この合金をこの形で、この速度で引き抜けば結晶がどう育つか。
何千何万回という実測値の積み重ねが、歩留まりを支える制御の中身になっている。
しかも合金はタービンメーカーごとに独自配合で、GE向けの部品で得たノウハウがそのままシーメンス向けには効かない。
加えて、タービンメーカーの認証を取るのに、既存の専門メーカーでさえ1つの部品につき1年〜1年半はかかる。
一から工場を建てる場合、さいしょの合格品が出るまで2年、まともな量産ペースに乗るまで3年以上というのが業界の相場観であり、そう簡単に参入できるわけではない。
相当な体力がある企業でないと、それまで資本が持たないだろう。
それに航空機エンジン用タービンであればタービンが破損すれば墜落するし、発電用タービンも長い年月使うものであるから破損して発電が出来ないなど許されるものではないのだ。
ガスタービンは売れすぎている
そして今、この4社の炉は全部予約で埋まっている。
GE Vernovaは第2四半期末の時点でガスタービンの受注残と予約枠を合わせて116ギガワット、2025年末の83ギガワットから半年で3割以上増えた。
GE Vernovaの投資家説明会では、2026年に新規注文を受けた大型ガスタービンの出荷は2031年になると説明していた。
シーメンス・エナジーは69ギガワットで納期3年以上、三菱重工の大型機の受注残も35ギガワット前後と伝えられる。
合計で220ギガワット分も注文待ちで、その1台1台に、この鋳造ブレードとベーンが何百枚と必要になる。
そうそう、ガスタービンメーカーは、さっきの4社にタービンブレードとベーンを外注しているのだ。
いちぶは自分たちでも作っているだろうが、大量に生産するとなると、外注するのだ。
ボトルネック、つまり最も難易度が難しく、製造が寡占状態になっていて困っているのはブレードとベーンであって、そこをなんとかしたいわけである。
マスクの分析は、少なくとも分析としては正しい。
問題は、4社が何十年かけて積み上げたものを、SpaceXが本当に数年で再現できるのかということである。
ただ、SpaceXはこの分野でまったくのゼロから始めるわけではない。
イーロン・マスクの製造業運営方法
SpaceXにはRaptorというエンジンがある。
Starshipに載っている液体メタンのロケットエンジンである。
フルフロー二段燃焼サイクルという、ソ連が1960年代に途中まで作って諦めた方式を、飛ぶエンジンとして初めて実用化したものでもある。
何が難しいかというと、燃料ポンプを回すタービンを、酸素過剰の高温ガスで回す。
圧力は800気圧。
酸素が多くて熱い場所に金属を置くと、たいていの金属はそのまま燃える。
マスク自身が2019年時点では「ほとんどの金属が耐えらない」と言っていた。
ここで使える材料がなかった。
だからSpaceXは社内に冶金チームを作り、SX300、続いてSX500という自前の超合金をかいはつした。
材料から自分たちで作るほど、SpaceXは製造業の鑑のような体制を取っているのは読者諸君も驚きかもしれない。
Raptorのターボポンプのタービン翼は当然ながらさっき書いた耐久性の高い単結晶の超合金でできていて、マニホールド(流路形成などにつかう金属部品)などはSX系の合金を精密鋳造で作っている。
初期のRaptorは3Dプリントを多用していたが、量産に向かないという理由で、SpaceXは版を重ねるごとに鋳造に寄せてきた。
前の章で説明した、真空炉、セラミックの殻、合金の設計、結晶を育てる工程。
その全部を、SpaceXは規模こそ小さいがすでに自分の手でやっている。
しかもRaptorは、量が要る。
Starshipは1段目に33基、2段目に6基、合わせて39基のエンジンを積む。
JAXA/三菱重工業のH3ロケットはせいぜい3−4基しか搭載してないが、39基も搭載している。
SpaceXが計画するようにStarshipを年に何百回も飛ばすなら、エンジンは年に何百基、いずれ千基の単位で必要になり、ターボポンプもその数だけ要る。
つまりSpaceXは、エーアイとは関係なく、もともと超合金のタービン翼を量産する工場を建てる必要があった。
Raptorの鋳物と発電用のブレードは、同じ合金、同じ炉、同じ技能の人間で作れる。
本来作る必要があった冶金工場の費用を、宇宙事業とエーアイ事業で割り勘にできる。
これがイーロン・マスクが考えたことだと思う。
イーロン・マスクが運営する会社には
、Idiot指数(アホ指数・バカ指数)
という言葉がある。
ある部品の完成品価格を、その材料費で割った数字だ。
この比率が高い部品は、材料は安いのに途中で誰かが法外な値段を乗せているか、工程が非効率かのどちらかで、それなら自分で作ったほうがいい、という判断の物差しになる。
「あんな高いもの買うなんてアホ」
ということなのだろう。
Nvidiaのジーピーユーなどは強烈なidiot指数だからいつか自分たちで半導体も作るのだろうか。
Falcon 9は部品の8割前後を社内で作っていると言われる。
Teslaは自動車メーカーとしては珍しく座席を自社で作り、自動運転用のチップも自前で設計し、テキサス州にリチウムの精錬所まで建てた。
2021年に半導体が世界的に足りなくなったときは、手に入る別のチップに合わせてファームウェアを書き直して乗り切った。
Starlinkのアンテナも、衛星同士をつなぐレーザーリンクも自社製だ。
トヨタとか日産とかホンダなどのように他社サプライヤー依存をしているのと大きく異なる。
毎回パターンは同じで、
外から買うと遅いか、高いか、そもそも手に入らない部品があると、その部品を作る工程ごと社内に取り込む
。
そうすると外の事情に左右されなくなり、速度が自分の手に戻ってくる。
ただ、今回はいつもの型と少し違うところがある。
タービンを丸ごと作るのではなく、タービンメーカーですら手に入らない部品だけを作る、という点だ。
タービン全体も5年待ちなんだから作ればいいのに、とゆな先生も当初は思った。
ここから先の使い方だが、ふたつの筋が考えられる。
ひとつは、
ブレードをGEやシーメンスや三菱重工に持ち込んで、自分のタービンを先に作ってもらう
筋である。
SpaceXは大型ガスタービンそのものを作れないから、機械はどのみち3社から買うしかない。
3社は部品待ちで生産が詰まっている。
だったら、部品はこっちで用意するから納期の列の前に入れてくれ、という交渉ができる。
イーロンマスクの投稿が
「タービンの稼働開始を早める」
という言い方をしているのは、この筋を指しているように読める。
もうひとつは、
鋳物を外販して、市場全体のきょうきゅうを増やす
筋だ。
こちらはSpaceXの部品がタービンメーカーの認証を通ることが前提になるので、時間がかかる。
ただ、もし通れば、4社しかいなかったしじょうに5社目が現れることになり、ブレードの値段と納期の主導権が動く。
どちらの筋になるかはまだ分からない。
ここは断定せず、両方の可能性を頭に置いておいたほうがいい。
場所の話もしておく。
SpaceXのタービンブレード冶金工場が作られる予定のバストロップという街はテキサス州の州都オースティンから車で30分ほどの町で、今やマスク帝国のテキサス側の拠点になっている。
Starlinkのアンテナ工場があり、ボーリング・カンパニーの本社があり、Xのオフィスもある。
その隣に830エーカーを足した。
求人票を見ると、工場の立ち上げを仕切る運営エンジニアのほかに、材料エンジニア、自動化エンジニア、治具のエンジニア、そして産業用ガスタービンのブレードとベーンの製造ラインで超合金を削るプログラマーを募集している。
名前は鋳造工場だが、削って仕上げるところまで一貫してやる構えだ。
それにしても1拠点だけでも凄い数の技術者求人を出している。
テキサス州の環境や建築の記録には、まだこの工場の許可申請が見つかっていない。
やり方はいつものイーロンと同じ。
人と炉と合金も作ったこともある。
それでも、発電用ガスタービン産業は何十年分のデータでできている。
マスクの方法論がどこまで通用するかは、正直まだ誰にも分からない。
そしてもうひとつ、この工場の前提になっている「ガスは太陽光への橋渡し」という言葉も、少し疑ってかかる必要がある。
太陽光100ギガワットとガスの本音
マスクの投稿の前半をもう一度読み返してみる。
「SpaceXとTeslaがそれぞれ年間100ギガワットの太陽光生産能力を全速力で整えている、天然ガスは太陽光を補い、立ち上げるために数年は必要」
ガスはあくまで橋渡しだという言い方だ。
この100ギガワットという数字は、ことし1月のダボス会議で本人が言い出したものだ。
3年以内に、TeslaとSpaceXがそれぞれ年産100ギガワットの太陽光発電能力をアメリカに作る。
別の場では、
ほかのエネルギー源は原始人が焚き火に小枝を投げ込んでいるようなもので、太陽光がすべて
だ、とまで言い切っている。
アメリカ国内の太陽光モジュールの製造能力は、2025年末で45ギガワットをやや上回る程度、2026年中に60ギガワットになる見込みだ。
中国は年間1500ギガワット前後。
やはり中国の工業きぼは桁違いである。
イーロンマスクは、今のアメリカの生産能力を遥かに上回るきぼを、自分の2社で整備すると言っている。
Teslaはマクスウェルなど中国のメーカーから29億ドル分のセル製造装置を買う契約を進めていて、納入は2026年後半。
それでも足りない。
太陽光の話は、金が動いているという意味で本気なのだろう。
ただ、1年では無理で3年かかる。
データセンターは2027年末までに10ギガワット欲しい。
その差を埋めるのがガスタービンだ、という筋書きは、それ自体としては辻褄が合っている。
夜も曇りの日も止められないデータセンターを太陽光だけで動かすには、蓄電池も含めて途方もない面積と量が必要で、1年やそこらでは間に合わないし、不安定過ぎる。
移動式ガスタービン提訴問題
2024年、xAIがColossus(第1号のエーアイデータセンター)を122日で立ち上げたとき、敷地には許可を取っていない移動式のガスタービンが並んでいた。
NAACP(全米黒人地位向上協会)と南部環境法律センターが問題にし、xAIは後から許可を申請して、小型の仮設タービンを州境を越えたミシシッピ州サウスヘイブンに移した。
わざわざ全米黒人地位向上協会が問題視してくるのは、こういう工場とか廃棄物がある系の設備は、だいたい土地が安くて貧しいエリアに設置されることから、環境問題を問題にすることが多い団体だからである。
ミシシッピ州環境局は、これらがトレーラーに載っている移動式の発電機だという理由で、1年間は大気の許可なしに運転できるとした。
イーロン・マスクもルールのギリギリを攻める男である。
1年以上同じ場所で回り続けている69基のタービンは、法律上どう見ても固定式だ、というもので、
NAACPは4月に連邦裁判所に提訴し、住民も6月に続いて提訴した。
その後、xAIが申請した恒久設置の41基に州の許可が下りた。
ちゃんと移動式ではなく、環境対応もした正規のガスタービン発電所をつくるというものであった。
その後州はついに69基の仮設タービンの撤去期限を決めた。
大半は2027年4月まで、さいごの一群は2027年7月14日まで。
もともとの期限は2026年12月31日だったが、延びた。
伸びた理由は、サプライチェーンの問題で、恒久タービンの建設が遅れているからとされている。
ここが今回の話とつながる。
仮設のタービンを設置し続けなければならず環境団体や州政府から訴訟されたり早期の撤去を求められるのは、環境に配慮した本設のタービンがきょうきゅうが足りず買えないからである。
本設のタービンが買えないのは、ブレードとベーンが足りないから
である。
SpaceXのタービンブレード鋳造工場は、足りない電力を増やす策であると同時に、仮設ガスタービン発電機で起きている法的な宿題を片付ける方策でもある。
そしてもうひとつ。
橋というのは、一度架かると道になるように、ガスタービン発電所も数年で撤去するわけがない。
太陽光が100ギガワット作れる日が来ても、そのタービンは撤去されない。
「数年」という言葉を、額面通りに受け取らないほうがいいと思うし、一度設置すればずっと使うと思う。
発電所というのは一度作ると何十年も使って償却していくのだ。
ソーラーと両立でやっていくのだろう。
ソーラーでは夜間の電力がなくなるし、TESLAの技術で作っているバッテリーに蓄電するとしても、ソーラーの不安定さを完全カバーはできまい。
誰が得をして、誰が困るか
ここからは投資家の目で見ていく。
ハウメットが7パーセント超の下げ、少し株価は戻している。
三菱重工業は日本株全体が落ちたりしているからそれ以外の影響もあるのだが、ハウメットの株式を投資家たちが売った理由は単純で、
イーロン・マスクのような格安でロケットや自動車を作れる会社が自分でブレードの鋳造を始めたら、ハウメットの商売はどうなるのか
、という連想であった。
この連想は正しいのだろうか。
このような材料工学的なものだと、ソフトウェアを作るようにはいかず、一から工場を建ててさいしょの合格品が出るまで2年、まともな量産まで3年以上はかかると考えるのが普通である。
SpaceXの工場建設許可申請はまだ見つかっていないし、つまりSpaceXの鋳物が意味のある量で出てくるのは、順調にいっても2028年から2029年。
その間、4社の炉は2030年まで埋まっている。
SpaceXが1枚ブレードを作ったところで、ハウメットの受注が1枚減るわけではない。
その間もエーアイじゅようが増えて電力は足りず、ガスタービン発電のじゅようは高まる。
足りないものが足りないままなのは変わらない。
ハウメットの利益の源泉は、そもそも発電用ではなく航空用で、特に飛んでいるエンジンの交換部品だ。
産業用ガスタービン向けは一部門にすぎない。
最近数年の株高を見ると、三菱重工もハウメットもだが、エーアイ向けのガスタービンじゅようをかなり織り込んでいる。
SpaceXがブレードを作れるようになるだろう2029年以降の値決めの主導権が揺らぐことに対してもう3年も前から株価が織り込み始めるという形で株価が下がった。
4社の寡占だったから通っていた価格と納期が、5社目が現れた瞬間に交渉の材料になる。
また、SpaceXが本当にやり遂げたら、次はグーグルやマイクロソフトが同じことを考えるかもしれない。
半導体製造はTSMCが頑張ってくれるだろうが、TSMCは発電施設までは作ってくれない。
ただ、グーグルやマイクロソフトが自前で工業製品を作る能力はないので、ブレードを作ることは無いと思う。
ついでに言うと、鋳造4社のうちじょうじょうしているのはハウメットのほかにドンキャスターズがあって、こちらはこの夏にDPCホールディングスとしてニューヨーク証券取引所にじょうじょうしたばかりである。
PCCはバークシャーの中にあって直接は買えない。
CPPは非公開。
ブレードの寡占に直接乗りたい人の選択肢は、実はかなり狭い。
どこかのはいぱーすけーらーがガスタービン発電企業を買収することはあるだろうか。
次にタービンメーカー。
GE Vernova、シーメンス・エナジー、三菱重工の3社にとって、この話はどちらに転んでも悪くない。
SpaceXの鋳物が自分たちの工場に流れてくるなら、部品待ちで止まっていたラインが動き、出荷が増える。
マスクがブレードを持ち込んで納期の列の前に割り込むなら、割り込まれた側の顧客は困るが、メーカーの売上は変わらない。
3社が失うとすれば、納期を握っていることで得ていた交渉上の強さくらいで、それも220ギガワットの受注残がある間は大した問題にならない。
実は、
マスクが今からやろうとしていることを、三菱重工はとっくにやっている。
三菱重工パワー精密鋳造という子会社があって、産業用ガスタービンの動翼と静翼を、超耐熱合金のロストワックス法で作っている
おい、作れるのは4社じゃなかったのかよ、と思うかもしれないが、ガスタービン発電機そのものを作れる会社を除いて4社である。
三菱重工も全量を自社製造しているわけではないが、三菱重工の35ギガワット前後の受注残は、外部の4社の炉の空き具合にそれほど縛られずにコントロールは効く。
自社の中で完結する意味は大きい。
垂直統合の効き目という意味では、三菱重工はイーロン・マスクのやろうとしていることを昔からやっていることになる。
IHI
も見ておきたい。
IHIキャスティングスという子会社が航空機エンジンのタービン翼を作っていて、一方向凝固と単結晶、セラミック中子を使った中空冷却翼に注力している。
さらにIHIマスターメタルは、単結晶と一方向凝固の鋳造用の母合金インゴットを作っていて、プラット・アンド・ホイットニーやGEアビエーション、ロールス・ロイスの認定を持つ。
航空とエーアイの二つの波が同じ鋳造能力に押し寄せているなら、その波は最終的に材料のところまで届く。
IHIが発電用に本気で舵を切るかどうかは別として、持っている技術は非常に似ている。
SpaceX自身についてはどのくらいの影響があるのだろう。
2兆ドルの時価総額の会社にとって鋳造工場ひとつのせつびとうしは誤差でしかない。
株価にとって影響があるとすれば、SpaceXのデータセンターのきぼが予定通り10ギガワットまでいくのか、5ギガワットで終わるのかに尽きる。
鋳造工場はその差を埋めるためのレバーだが、許可はまだなく、技術の再現には年単位かかる。
だかららいねんいきなりブレードとベーンが完成してデータセンターの電力逼迫が解決するわけではないと考えて良いと思う。
それまではどちらかというと仮設ガスタービン発電機で凌ぐのかもしれない、
上場から180日でさいしょのロックアップが明ける12月のほうが、鋳造工場のニュースよりも影響が大きいと考えて良い。
こんごの動きとして、ゆな先生は以下を見ていこうと考えている。
1つ目は、バストロップで環境や建築の許可申請が実際に出るか。
2つ目は、Raptor側の鋳物でもいいから、SpaceXの単結晶部品が量産に乗ったという話が出るか。
3つ目は、ハウメットとドンキャスターズの決算説明で、受注残と価格についての言い方が変わるか。
日本株だと三菱重工が一番影響が大きいから、ガスタービン発電しじょうにどのような影響があるかはこんご半年〜1年程度の報道や現地の建設状況や許可状況などをよく見ていく必要がある。
18カ月でいけるか
18ヶ月という根拠は、イーロン・マスクは特に説明はしていない。
ただ、今日GE Vernovaとか三菱重工に大型ガスタービン発電機を注文すると、出荷は2031年になるとする。
もしSpaceXの鋳造工場が2028年か2029年に認証付きのブレードを出せるようになり、それをタービンメーカーに持ち込んで組み立ての順番を繰り上げてもらえたら、納入は2029年の後半か2030年になる。
差し引きで、まあ18カ月。
そういう計算なら間違っていない。
2027年末の10ギガワット構想は、APR Energyの移動式タービンとかFTAIの航空転用機で凌ぐしかない。
イーロン・マスクの時間の読みは、当たらないことのほうが多い。
完全自動運転は10年近く遅れているし、火星に人はまだ行っていない。
いっぽうで、工場を建てる速さについては、彼の実績は本物である。
工場建設は変態的に速い。
上海のギガファクトリーは着工から1年足らずで車を出荷し始めた。
日本だったら3-4年はかかってると思う。
Colossus1は122日、サウスヘイブンの発電設備は5カ月で27基から69基になった。
たぶん世界最速で工場を作る能力がある。
でも時間は外す。
鋳造工場も、3年と言えば5年かかるつもりで見ておくのがいいと思う。
それでも、ゆな先生はこの一手には合理性があると思っている。
理由は、失敗したときの損が著しく小さいからである。
先ほど解説した通り、SpaceXはエーアイと無関係に、Raptorエンジンのターボポンプ用の超合金鋳物を量産する工場をどのみち必要としていた。
発電用のブレードに手が届かなかったとしても、炉と人と合金はロケットに使える。
逆に、届いたときの見返りは、エーアイ電力の一番細いボトルネックを自分の手で握るということで、利益が大きい。
損は限定、益は大きい。
イーロン・マスクがこういう形の賭けを好むのは、今に始まったことではない。
何十年もかけてノウハウを貯めた4社に対して、SpaceXは速く失敗して速く学ぶという文化で挑むのだろう。
ロケットを爆発させながらもStarshipを作ってきた会社が、1時間に数ミリしか進まない結晶の成長を相手にして、同じことができるのか。
答えが出るのは、たぶん2028年ごろになる。
それまでにバストロップの許可が出て、さいしょの鋳物が炉から出て、どこかのタービンメーカーがそれを自社の機械に入れると言うかどうか。
見るべきものはそれだけで、それまでは静かに見守る。
三菱重工の株価にも影響するし、電力のきょうきゅうがはいぱーすけーらーやエーアイ企業のパワーバランスにも影響するので、重要である。
終わりに
ロケット会社が鋳物工場を建てるというのは、不思議な話だと思った人もいるかもしれない。
だが、エーアイは半導体だけでなく、電力のほうが先に足りなくなるというのは言われて久しい。
米国の電力網はかなり古くせつびとうしもされておらず脆弱だが、日本もまた電力が足りなくてデータセンターの建設は順番待ちである。
電気代もエーアイの価格競争に大きく影響し、電気代が安い中国などは、やすい人件費、電気代を武器に低価格のエーアイをどんどん打ち出している。
エーアイエージェントなどが拡大すれば、エーアイのトークン数はもっともっと使われるようになり、その分電気も消費されていく。
最終的には小型原発などに落ち着くのだろうが、それまでの10年20年は、ガスタービンに注目が集まる。
果たしてこの分野もイーロン・マスクが無双するのだろうか。
これから数年、その過程をぜひ見守っていきたいと思う。
きょうはここまで。
諸君らの投資の成功を祈っている。
ゆな先生より
スキする
コメントする
メンバーシップ
ゆな先生経済日記
プラン
ゆな先生日記　基本プラン
ゆな先生 さん
億り人の投資家かつしがない労働者です
さいきんの記事を見る
ヘルプ /
利用規約
以上で今回の放送を終わります。
またお聞きください。